when you live a clutter-free life when  you have a life filled with organization  you it is a form of self-care it is  Wellness it is the a little bit of Zen  and you know we often talk about  controlling the controllables because so  much of life is chaotic and if you can  just add a little bit of order to your  life it's amazing how much it how how  long it goes and how much it benefits  you an organization is an opportunity  people see it as a chore but I think  it's about reframing your thinking and  realizing this is an opportunity and  being excited about it be better than  love making  I don't know I cleaned out my closet  this morning and I was like yep Better  Than Sex  i i i i freed myself of demons that were  coming out of this tiny coat closet  something about a foot and a half by two  feet deep but boy that thing had  skeletons and demons in it